un chat siamois
un perroquet
une guitare une bibliothèque
tel est l'univers méconnu dans lequel le
plus attachant des bois de la chanson à
préparer son retour au music hall et
quel retour puisque georges brassens
tiendra la scène trois mois quelle
impression éprouvez vous à quelques
heures de faire votre rentrée à paris
après deux ans et demi à la fois une
impression désagréable et puis une
impression un peu d'eau j'ai un peu j'ai
un peu peur maintenant l'appeler mes
textes je suis dans l'état de du
visiteur le programme ce qui revient du
vieil oncle la province qui revient
après quelques années je ne sais pas
combien ton vieux remplace-t-il je pense
qu'on va induire gentil moi je sais pas
c'est toujours un peu gênant de
reprendre contact est le public et
surtout le point de contact même des
chansons que je n'avais pas les
anciennes surtout je n'avais pas
d'écouté depuis deux ans dites moi j'en
pense avez vous le sentiment d'être à
part un peu sur votre petit nuage
personnel ou de faire partie du monde de
la chanson
il est difficile de savoir quelle part
il faut faire
le sentiment pur fun la connaît avec le
sentiment qui vous vient de l'extérieur
on rencontre tellement de choses sur les
gens qui sont un peu connu ils finissent
quand même par se demander si si les
sentiments visé pour vous livre les
idées qu'ils ont pu croître à voir leur
appartienne viennent de l'extérieur ne
sais pas si j'occupe une place au
parlement je n'ai pas l'impression
d'occuper une place à part la gomme
depuis des années on me le répète je
finis par évidemment le croire amgen nos
jeunes
y at-il selon vous une évolution dans le
goût du public sur plein de la
sensibilité politique en ce qui concerne
la sensibilité poétique
je ne sais pas si je vois ça mon point
de vue c'est difficile puisque je ne
suis pas je ne suis pas en contact
depuis trois ans je pense que le public
le public et quand même sensiblement nos
changements
je pense qu'en surface il ya toujours
des changements n'est que le pont au
reste le même alors comment
expliquez-vous le phénomène de votre
actualité permanente et que même au
temps le yéyé sévices et vous étiez
georges brassens et très haut de
l'échelle
je ne l'exclus pas constaté je crois
aussi pouvoir l'expliquer pense que dans
mes chansons des gens qui les écoutent
trouve quelque chose qui l'intéresse
j'entre je ne crois pas du tout aux
modes vous savez j'ai toujours contesté
la la valeur des modes une mode est
valable pendant ce temps et puis mais
les choses qui sont si vous voulez
qu'ils sont presque traditionnelle après
les choses qui sont faites
les convictions emporte toujours quand
même la faveur du public genre grâce à
110 toujours que vous vivez en sauvage
entre mm
estimez vous que c'est vrai bien sûr que
non une fois pour toutes a écrit cela je
suis tout le confort sa vache à lait
d'ailleurs déjà dit cela mais ça n'a pas
d'importance vous savez on a besoin
toujours de mettre des étiquettes
sionneau des gens c'est plus facile pour
lui le jour de la saint barthélemy mais
c'est je ne crois pas que je ne crois
pas trop beau je crois même un point de
ce1 et moins sauvage parmi tous ceux que
je connais par la chance comment
expliquer qu'il pense à ce que quand on
veut pas quand on compte pour la
première fois on a envie de vous dire
bonjour monsieur bras salle alors que
quand on rencontre d'autres
personnalités de la chanson leur dit
bonjour comme ça je ne sais pas pourquoi
pas je suis le seul qu'on puisse aborder
sans dire bonjour monsieur sommet non je
crois aussi que ça relève d'une
tradition ça parce que des gens ont dû
le dire parce que quelquefois des gens
des rois ça c'est un type respectable je
n'aime pas tellement qu'on ne respecte
pas ce point mais il croit que peut-être
ça convient mieux aux gens que je fais
alors je ne suis pas tellement votre
spectacle dans ce que j'écris finale
enfin les cheveux qui va le
j'aurais dorénavant des difficultés
fendre le avons vient le vent tout est
bon chez bell oeil à vienne a jeté sur
l'île déserte il faut toute femme forte
le me demande encore rome où subsistent
et censure ou de mouvements de belles
pommes nouvelle le tout chaque jour
tout est bon chez elle le yen à jeter
sur l'île déserte il faut tout en beauté
sans sa loge mater est dépourvu de
coussins reposerait par terre rien n'est
plus malsain tout est bon chez elle le
ya rien à jeter sur l'île déserte il
faut tout en beauté